the entire village have gathered to
celebrate the end of the rice harvest my
failed attempt at rice cakes won't be on
offer so I helped to serve up instead
right where do we start with this
fabulous feast look at this
do you take you take the rice and pass
it along and using my box rice paper
making has obviously done the rounds my
job what do you think I do
actor no a doctor I'm a cook
good luck for next year's harvest
happy harvest I have been useless but
Sowers honored my trip with a gift of
rice from the village I will do the rice
justice okay they treat it like gold
they show it so much respect they have a
huge technical ability to make rice so
fantastic it's it's at a different level
it's been an amazing week but tomorrow
it's crunch time I'll be in Hanoi to
prove to rest on to a V that I've
cracked Vietnamese cuisine so lots of
things bubbling and festering away now
in my mind and all I need is to
disappear somewhere quiet and just start
nailing down those issues
you